[Musique]
oui bien à part à l'automne et cissé
mais sa mort lundi puis cette semaine je
veux qu'on célèbre encore une fois
l'histoire ou plutôt les choses qu'il
faut pour remettre dans l'histoire parce
que ce mois ci c'est le mois de
l'histoire des noirs
je préfère souvent dire le mois de
l'histoire des personnes afro
descendantes et j'entends encore une
fois les gens d'hellemmes compliqué tout
avec vos mots mais non pour moi c'est
pas compliqué puisque dire le mois de
l'histoire des noirs c'est comme dire le
mois de l'histoire des personnes
autochtones cdtm pas ni pour soutenir
plusieurs identités très riche très
varié qui existe au canada
donc avant de me faire dire que je suis
une femme autochtone j'aime beaucoup
plus dire que je suis une femme innu je
pense que beaucoup de personnes
afrodescendantes qui préfèrent se faire
définir par leur histoire
d'origine et pourquoi il ya cette
histoire d'origine des personnes noires
est si varié et bien c'est qu'il remonte
aux débuts de la colonisation avec la
présence des personnes afrodescendantes
dans notre histoire au canada et aux
états unis
cependant au canada et une très grande
ignorance de l'histoire justement la
présence des personnes afrodescendantes
dans l'adn du pays même beaucoup de gens
ignorent qu'ils avaient de l'esclavagé
au canada qui avait eu justement des
histoires qui a été transporté dans la
colonie française et anglaise et c'est
souvent même une histoire qu'on préfère
ne pas partager parce qu'elle n'est pas
si glorieux et surtout on l'aimé et on
la compare où on oppose même à celle des
états unis où le déplacement brutale des
personnes qui n'étaient continent
africain c'est fait pour une économie
colonialiste une économie basée sur
l'esclavagé de personne humaine
bien sûr c'est pas les seuls à avoir
fait seul mais on aime beaucoup dans
l'imaginaire des films dans l'imaginaire
des histoires des livres
ce n'est que c'était beaucoup plus
rossellini okada nos esclaves étaient
bien traités et malheureusement ce mythe
fondateur permet d'oublier qu'il y aura
une présence
d'esclaves qui était quand même énorme
au canada et pourquoi norme c'est qu'il
ya eu aussi de l'accueil des escarres de
ces états unis s'est faite au canada
particulièrement dans les maritimes et
ça lui permet aux gens de renom le
sauver les personnes qui étaient liés à
l esclavage
alors que malgré tout malgré ce beau
sauvetage
on a quand même au canada fait de la
ségrégation de la même manière qu'eux il
y avait aux états unis jusque dans les
années 60 70
c'était clairement une forme de
séparation des communautés et on peut
pas ignorer qu aujourd'hui encore des
problématiques liées à au racisme et au
racisme sitting cependant tous les
personnes d'approuver descendance ne
sont pas liées à l'esclavagé des états
unis il ya des personnes qui vont venir
aussi d'haïti des personnes vont venir
de là jamais il ya des personnes qui
vont venir aussi directement eux-mêmes
du continent africain de plusieurs pays
et venir vivre au canada
donc même si des fois on aime mettre une
identité immigrants à nos nouveaux
citoyens
il reste que leur vie vient ce mélange à
la nôtre bien faire partie de la souche
qu'est le canada et le québec et ses
identités lob bien ce sont la future
histoire de nos enfants nos
petits-enfants donc il faut voir comment
les identités historique autochtone les
audits et historiques sont encore d
identité historique satellite à la
grande histoire du cade et en essayant
de l'intégrer de l'enseigné aussi aux
jeunes ou membres de la communauté
canadienne
et bien c'est encore compliqué 11e but
encore pourquoi je prendrais cette
histoire là c'est pas mon histoire alors
que oui c'est d'histoire du canada et le
gendarme aussi une question mais
pourquoi est ce que tu faisais pendant
une chronique autochtone c'est qu'il
faut pas oublier que nous mêmes on a une
histoire qui est imbriqué avec ceux des
personnes afro descendants ne serait ce
que par le fait que même pendant les
l'esclavagé il y avait des communautés
qui ont aidé les esclaves en fête ou
même qui avait des communautés qui
avaient des experts eux mêmes
donc cette histoire ne peut pas ignorer
peut pas être embellie ou est facile
elle doit être enseigné pour ne pas être
répétée et aujourd'hui
vous serez étonné d'apprendre à les
inouk mariage gay sénégalais il ya des
haïtiens qui se marient avec des cris et
ses enfants là vont rester les membres
la communauté autochtone mais avec des
héritages qui ne sont pas uniquement
liées aux personnes eurocentré au canada
donc en créant ces nouvelles identités
l'heure d'une façon éclairée en
apprenant l'histoire on ne les fasse un
pas bien on renforce justement didier
canadienne on évite de faire confiance à
une réécriture de l'histoire qui peut
nous revenir en plein mais si on décide
de l'ignorer alors ces mois ci essayait
de célébrer essayer de découvrir
justement comment l'histoire du canada
des états unis
les personnes afrodescendantes
autochtone québécoises canadiennes ont
été mélangées ensemble est plutôt que de
vouloir réécrire l'histoire plutôt
embrasser ce qui s'est passé pour
justement ne plus jamais répéter les
airs alors je souhaite une belle semaine
et ce n'est pas nous envoyer des
questions et c'était pas surtout à
partager ses vidéos